I also wanted to ask about the scene
that Stephen King told you to add to it
because if I hear that Stephen King of
all people added the scenes of this
movie that thrills me to no end so I'm
curious which one was it
that's not true he's unfortunate no it's
a like a broken you know like
communication Steve I love this man and
and he's been so supportive of this no I
just like share the script with him and
I because I wanted to know you know what
he thought about it his you know he has
any kind of note and he very you know
very very generously said look this is
not don't take it just take this as what
it is it's not a mandate or anything but
this is like the couple of things that I
would like to see in the movie and and
that's that's what you know what can you
share any particular note seeking no no
yes I know all of Stephen King secrets
he wanted to you know he there were
things that were already on their way to
land in the movie he will he was you
know he's a fan of Paul Bunyan and Paul
Bunyan and especially specifically
probing and chasing young Richie so that
was great because you know I was a
little bit on the on the on the fence
with that and when Steve said and I put
it in the MOOC and if we scan we see it
in the voice like yes of course and the
other one was the the rolling standpipe
at the end of you know in the book when
Derry collapses into the sinkhole and it
all floods there is a scene there where
the standpipe basically collapses and
starts rolling down the hill and for
some reason is one of Steven's favorite
like episodes indepen the book and it's
funny actually there's like it seemed
like the whole episode was seen by a
where a guy that is like you know
smoking a spliff and it's looking at
it's like he says something like he'd
that Steven Spielberg something like
that because of the scope of a scene
well we couldn't go that far because I
would you know I basically wanted to end
the movie in a more emotional no more
to make more and more about the feelings
up of this group of characters and also
like making this like huge
you know destruction scene would have
sucked probably have a budget of visual
effects I didn't go I don't want to go
through that yeah